This is really interesting. I guess the fact the
we have these three buckets, the number of critical
resources, the number of critical bytes and path points,
illustrates that there's really no one golden rule. For
example, if I eliminate the number of critical resources,
I would also probably also reduce the number of
bytes. And likewise if I started compressing, caching and
minifying, I can also produce a number of bytes.
>> Exactly. I couldn't have said it better myself. I
think you're really starting to get a hang of this.
Let's try a few more examples. Okay same page but now with CSS and JavaScript.
Once again we get the HTML and
let's cover CSS and JavaScript resources and initiate
those requests. Note that the JavaScript file is a bit smaller than the CSS so
it may arrive sooner. Which other script is
blocked on this CSS on being created, right?
>> Correct, once the CSS arrives the browser builds
this CSS object model which unblocks java script and
allows it to execute. Once the java script is
executed, the DOM parser becomes unblocked which means a
complete DOM construction. And finally we have both the
DOM and the CSS object model which means that
we can render the page. As you can see,
even a simple page such as this one has
a lot of dependencies that slow down the critical path.
>> Yeah, no kidding.